[Music]
after the first game released
we had that itch to go back and revive
some of the material that landed on the
cutting room floor well looks like it's
bound voyage to our old pals cuphead bug
man and the lovely miss chalice
they're off on their next adventure this
time to the table dlc island the
delicious last course is more
fantastical cartoon action
it's a true second helping of screen
filling boss battles imaginative stages
and new powers
this new adventure and expansion lets us
really give miss chalice a chance to
shine
[Music]
we had always envisioned her playing a
really important role as part of the
main trio of heroes this was our
opportunity to further explore animation
music
gameplay homages all of which we didn't
get to in the first game
[Music]
the origin of the original cuphead
character
we probably went through about 300
concepts
we began brainstorming in the 1930s
tradition of giving inanimate objects
faces and personalities
we really wanted to create essential
character that could sit alongside some
of the iconic joyful heroes we loved
growing up like felix the cat and mickey
and bimbo
and then one day we just had one of
those
amazing aha moments when a loose sketch
of a silhouette of a cup and a straw
began to take form that would eventually
become
cuphead
[Music]
having the chance to re-explore this
world to make something special for our
fans while taking our time
on the little details and making sure
we're getting them just right in so many
ways cuphead
game and character has been with our
whole team through life's many changes
these characters have become like
children of sorts and getting a chance
to take them on a new adventure to close
this chapter of their story is
just really exciting
well there's a new challenge waiting
around every corner on the amazing dlc
island
[Applause]